let's take another question another call
that came in here this is Rudy from
Chicago
I got a question for Bobby Bobby steel
has stated at the Joe Rogan experience
that if he was ever stranded in an
island he would be aging that first now
what would you taste like to feel or
vice versa but with do taste like if you
had eaten love you guys guys would you
not wait oh I would love the white
really yeah I have a little bit of
[ __ ] honky in the afternoon no I
would do it out of anger really yeah I
feel like you faked this role that you
hate whites though I don't hate whites
cuz a lot of your friends are white I've
seen you with whites no I love whites
Eric Griffin's half white dude I'm white
all day I hang out once all day yeah but
what I'm saying that in an island
situation mm-hmm I would be like I would
eat you because I know that I would be
the first on your menu mm-hmm so I'm
gonna get to you first
yeah because why would you want to eat
Asians first you know it happened with
me I went on a fast one time and I you
know I mean people know this but I
almost [ __ ] they had this do to the
best fathers best boy named bin and I
think he might have been a man you don't
know you know you guys are kind of
hide-and-go-seek when it comes to what
age you are and but he I was so hungry I
hadn't eaten in five days and I thought
I could eat this man like everybody kind
of I just had this weird thought calm my
head like I could [ __ ] eat this guy
yeah and he was Vietnamese and I knew
right hand the way you say that though
Vietnamese is real crazy like what do
you mean Vietnamese I mean the way you
say it
I move on neck like that they in the
maze it's like you're back in Nam and
you're low bruh and you're Kevin Dillon
and you get your shooting of Vietnamese
guys the leg he's hopping up and down
you know year Dan's Vietnamese do you
make it sound like a condiment day yeah
yellow the fries and the Vietnamese
you squirt a little more Vietnamese on
those dude no I say the Viet bro yes yes
yeah I'll [ __ ] gum down a Viet in a
heartbeat man yeah I think I yeah
Vietnamese people to me very much a
delicacy very much edible and very like
passionate to the bay yeah no you don't
think nah man I think that what are you
gonna eat a deer you need a black woman
who should be pissed
what are you gonna [ __ ] eat yeah it
her just yeah I don't have her leg but
she just sit up there like she's dead
but she still that's her life reflexes
you know made of that she no I would um
let's see what we were stranded I'll be
honest it's not a race thing right it's
who I could eat right you know mean so
it's like a baby a [ __ ] no the Brad
Williams ooh I could probably eat him I
could see my feet look so long I doesn't
matter I'm heavier I do a double leg I'd
sweep the leg right sweep the leg you
gonna be able to do that yeah because
all ankle to his ankles gonna kick I
know I'll sweep his ankle yeah whatever
the bottom has a long ankle
yeah whatever the bottom half of his
body is like a foot and a half ankle
right I would sweep it okay he'd get on
his back okay I would take a piece of
bamboo I don't know what Highland were
on Yeah right and I would just
repeatedly hit his [ __ ] mmm yeah damn
right then I would stick the bamboo like
cuz his head's off I would stick it
through that little opening where from
his net where his neck is I know stick
the bamboo all the way in and I would
just take pic pick him up like this like
he's a popsicle it has no roasting fire
and I would just roast him like that and
with his clothes on it as well
right cuz it was just burn off right his
clothes would burn off unless he's
wearing plastic and what kind of it's
condiment would you put on him I'll just
eat it raw I mean just like what part of
the body would yeah at first that is
because midgets have big asses
mmm that fatty big ass oh alright
this fatty [ __ ] big ass dude you're
going to hell no dude imagine them
melting your mouth that fat
yeah and imagine then you going directly
to him
yeah not pass heaven do not collect 200
you would eat the Asian though why me I
kind of eat a [ __ ] what's up guys
sitting here with this marijuana plant I
think also could be just a regular plant
it could be poison ivy brought about to
smoke myself in some itchy itchy just
watch another clip since you're already
here you know I'm saying